investigators in beirut lebanon are
working to find out if tuesday's
gigantic explosion was caused by
negligence
the blast killed at least 135 people
including one american
around five thousand others are injured
mts tayab is in beirut where a massive
recovery effort
is underway mts what do you see there
well you know coming into this city that
i know so well i've
never seen it devastated quite like this
before a quarter of a million people
made homeless in a matter of seconds now
we haven't learned much more about the
american who was killed in this blast
or the several other americans who were
injured but we do know that a vast
search and rescue effort
continues this hellscape was once
beirut's
port now laid to waste by over 2700 tons
of ammonium nitrate
how such a vast quantity of such
volatile material
was allowed to rot for over six years in
a warehouse so close to the city center
is still being investigated the lebanese
government is putting the port's
managers under house arrest
while it pieces together how the russian
known cargo ignited
many here are blaming the country's
ruling elite after
reports surfaced suggesting officials
had repeatedly warned the dangerous
chemicals
needed to be removed so few were spared
including little sophie in intensive
care whose brain is bleeding from
shattered glass
her parents say they also lost their
home
i tried to protect her but i couldn't do
more than this
[Music]
[Applause]
baby yes
there are still some moments of hope
like when rescuers pulled this man from
the rubble
16 hours after the explosion
there's also music 78 year old may
maliki survived lebanon's 15-year civil
war
and later conflicts with israel
her home may now be in ruins but her
piano skills
and resolve are as strong as ever each
time
these catastrophes happen we stand
up and start again
now lebanon has been suffering on so
many fronts first the crashing economy
then the pandemic and now this disaster
this isn't a country that's on the brink
it's deep in the abyss
eureka mts tide force in beirut thank
you